all right outrage republicans including
our next guest accused speaker pelosi of
prioritizing
marijuana over coronavirus relief as
democrats push a bill to legalize pot
while millions of americans devastated
by the pandemic wait for
a deal all right house minority leader
kev mccarthy joins us right now i
believe from our nation's capital
uh thank you very much leader for
joining us thank you good morning
it's all about priorities uh you you may
want to help people
who are you know they don't have any
money because of the pandemic but nancy
pelosi wants to work on cannabis and
cats
as you tweeted well that is so true you
know 38 times since the summer the
democrats have voted against any coveted
relief
with all the challenges america has
right now we think covered relief should
be on the floor
but instead the democrats put cats and
cannabis this week
they're going to outlaw big tigers and
then they're going to
legalize cannabis they're picking weed
over the workers they're picking
marijuana over helping the much needed
money we need to go forward
the small businesses that are closing we
look at what's happening
to max public maybe if they were named
french laundry it would be okay i don't
understand the double standards of what
we see from these democratic leaders
how many times did speaker pelosi tell
us we would not leave
congress until we got some covert relief
bill
that was months ago there is a there is
a discharge petition on the floor that
democrats can sign that they said they
would and they haven't
that would bring money to the small
business workers
there are the number of times we've been
here but now they schedule the floor
they put cats and cannabis but not covet
it's just unbelievable how do they not
have a heart for these people that can't
pay their bills right now
and people are worried about losing
their jobs where do you stand when it
comes to the stimulus package because i
know pelosi and schumer are saying
908 billion in that bipartisan deal
mcconnell and mnuchin 500 billion what
do you say
i stand with mitch mcconnell and mnuchin
because think about what we're doing
here it's even more
there's 138 billion that's already
appropriated
that is sitting there for small business
workers but pelosi won't let that go
forward
there's more than a hundred billion
that's already been appropriated
that would go to states that help them
with their schools and the unemployment
and others
we can do this in a systematic way to
help those who need it with not adding
more money because we've already
have the money the democrats won't allow
it to be spent
yeah i i just hope it's it's a
bipartisan situation she came down off
2.4
uh down to one eight and now she'll take
900 billion
you've got democrats and republicans
working on it kevin i hope i hope you
guys get something done this week
because they obviously feel the pressure
to move and you're about to get even
more
uh more power because the majority right
now
the majority when you start in january
it could be from two you told me the
numbers
222 to 213. so you they're going to be
democrats who are already defecting from
them they're going to she's going to
need republicans to pass anything
so maybe you guys can get together and
lay the groundwork for something
bipartisan
but something else is going on in in uh
california that thing is significant
your two-faced politicians are telling
the people to do one thing
and they're doing the exact other here's
bill mcluhan
he's from uh kttv over in california
uh he broke this story
i was tipped off about this by several
people in the restaurant industry who
were
less than pleased because they say this
is yet another glaring example of
hypocrisy
from our local politicians so we've been
trying to get an interview with
supervisor kewl all day long today
and they've been telling us her camp has
been telling us she's too busy she's in
meetings all day long
well turns out that's not true because
she just had an interview with another
affiliate here in l.a where she
is playing the victim and essentially
said she's getting death threats and
that she came here because she wanted to
personally deliver the news to the
restaurant that she was going to
put them out of business strange
explanation well she's talking about
people who go to say
ban outdoor dining and then go do
outdoor dining like your governor
and like your mayor what's your reaction
to your state
uh just having this uh double standard
this double standard
these double standards are despicable i
mean if every restaurant in california
would just change their name to the
french laundry
i guess it would be okay because you
have them the mayor of san francisco she
was at the french laundry
the governor he's at the french laundry
with no mass sitting next to the medical
lobbyists for association it's okay if
you're one of these elite
democrats that dictate what you can do
in your life
but not within their own they could do
whatever they want or maybe the mayor of
austin
that that films that you should not
leave while sitting in cancun
this is what makes america so mad
these are our democratic leaders that
think they are above
everyone else and can tell us what to do
but again they could do
whatever they want we have only seen
this in these socialist
countries of these elitists instead of
understanding
what do the workers need what do those
who are being harmed so much
what about those children who can't be
in school that we could have resources
to protect them
to help those who are unemployed to help
those small businesses
i was a small business owner i know what
it's like to have a dream
but to have government crush you in
every aspect
that's just despicable and you left out
speaker nancy pelosi who when the salons
were closed
she went in she got her hair done no
mask and then
she blamed the salon owner salon owner
set me up
darn it i didn't do anything wrong all
right leader mccarthy thank you very
much for joining us live today
thank you